if a man has this mother complex
then how does he experience women in
real life if a man has a too close
tie to his mother then he especially a
positive one
then he he tends to idealize women
and he sees in every woman the beatrice
of dante so to speak
or the virgin mary and then
such men cannot approach women again
with their lower parts with with
sexually and and in ordinary human life
or they have a split animal situation
they admire
a very unapproachable
lofty beautiful girl from afar and
satisfy their sexual desires with
prostitutes
and cannot bring the two ends together
they cannot put the princess and the
beach together so to speak in their
psyche
and that is generally due to a too close
tie to the mother in the man he has to
free himself from the mother
that's why for instance in one of the
famous examples
of such a princess in the tower rapunzel
she's imprisoned by a witch
it's the mother figure behind the scene
which brings forth the constellation and
then both lovers cannot
meet on earth and only when rapunzel has
come
down on earth and he has heard around in
the desert
in misery and pain can they finally meet
[Music]